mariah is with us in Fort Smith Arkansas
hey Mariah how are you I'm good how
about you
better than I deserve what's up so my
husband and I have a little over six
thousand dollars worth of debt after we
have labor and delivery bills come in
and we make about combine a little
around thirty thousand a year and I just
I feel like we bit off more than we can
chew I'm not sure where to start on
getting that tree though okay but you're
in the middle of having a baby right we
just had her in February oh okay
okay I'm sorry I missed that part okay
and so you're home still are you back to
work I am back to work okay what is your
drum around 30,000 a year between both
of you working yeah well somebody's not
working much who is that I make 800 a
month in he works in construction so it
can vary rainy days can change it I mean
it's annika which are not working 40
hours for $800 a month no I am part-time
okay what do you do
I'm the childcare okay okay all right so
we've got $30,000 a year and you've got
what kind of debt it's a little over
$6,000 most of it is credit cards okay
and no other debt no car payment no
student loan I do have a car payment so
that the Karpin is 18,000 Oh
the carpet the car theme is 319 re yeah
we owe 18,000 sell the car you cannot
afford an $18,000 car on a $30,000
income the car is killing you okay and
if it hasn't killed you it will slowly
kill you before you realize it you
should never own vehicles that equal
more than half your annual income all of
them together okay if you own another
car it would be added in that's him
equation yeah you've got a car you
cannot afford here
it's killing there was a complete
impulse you buy the car because of the
baby
yes yeah there's a van or something it's
at top oh wow okay yeah babies have
survived in cheap cars but even before
there were cars so your baby will
survive in that and we've got to do a
cut then then we've got to work to get
out of debt the answer to getting out of
debt and building wealth in for you all
is twofold one it is the part-time job
for your husband the good news is he's
in construction and construction is
booming so he can work all he wants to
work somewhere yeah and so he's just
about to double his hours because y'all
got a mess to clean up and so he's gonna
work all the time til he's just
exhausted to clean up this mess that's
the short-term answer and along with
selling the car and you're gonna get you
a beater car to get around in then the
long-term answer is you start asking
yourself what do I want to be doing you
and your husband 10 years from now that
makes 2 or 3 times more money than I'm
making now because it's tough to raise a
family on $30,000 a year right so we've
got to do something to get our incomes
up and that may mean take some classes
it may mean a certification it may just
mean a career change it maybe he's in
the construction business maybe he
apprentices on a carpentry thing or one
of the mechanicals maybe he learns to be
a plumber or a heat in the air or
whatever I don't care where we go but
doing what you're doing 10 years from
now would be bad so and the only way
you're not going to be doing that is to
be very intentional so work like crazy
people on the short-term let's get your
income up get the $6,000 cleaned up get
you an emergency fund
get you a paid four or five thousand
dollar car get rid this $18,000 car long
term you're going to have to adjust your
careers and make some decisions on that